it was literally the greatest like
moment of
one of the greatest moments of my life
obviously but i mean
it was beyond what i thought it was
going to be gwen stefani is
pure honeymoon bliss after her recent
wedding to blake shelton
sometimes i just feel like i'm in a
dream gwen and blake tied the knot
at the country star's oklahoma ranch
earlier this month
and on tuesday's episode of the tell me
about it with jade iovine podcast
the singer opened up about the picture
perfect ceremony
adding that she's never been happier or
more at peace than she is now
i just feel so lucky and i don't know i
think one of those things that you think
about a lot in your life
is you just you don't know the future
and you don't know what's gonna happen
but i feel like my
spiritual journey has really guided me
towards this place
and this place of peace and just sort of
um
now i just need to figure out how to uh
do
the rest of my life gwen says a lot of
that piece has come from her now hubby
who
she called quote very real and
consistent
that man he is the same guy that you see
no matter who he's with what he's doing
you know
if he's i look at him sleeping and he's
the same guy you know what i'm saying
he's just a good
guy consistent he's very real and
consistent and genuine and so it's like
um that i think is what is so attractive
i totally love him so much the two said
i do
in a very intimate ceremony surrounded
by family
in a chapel on blake's property that he
had built
just for the occasion i was only trying
to impress gwen
a source told et at the time quote it
was
absolutely a picture-perfect intimate
wedding with family
everyone at the wedding was so thrilled
to see gwen and blake
finally get married they have been
talking about a wedding for so long
and wanted nothing more than to
officially call themselves a family
it was a fairy tale experience even for
the guests
it's very emotional the couple married
six years after
unexpectedly finding love on the voice
and the show's host
carson daly officiated their ceremony at
the wedding gwen starts
and she wrote this i mean like since i
was a little girl blah blah blah
and she crushes not a dry eye in the
church
we are all like and it was so perfect
that i said flake when she was done i'm
like top that butt
carson opened up about the couple's big
day on the today show revealing blake
wrote a song for his bride and blake
starts by saying you know gwen's always
giving me a hard time about
not writing enough songs yeah so i wrote
a song
guitar comes in frame stool next thing
he wrote her a song and he sings her a
song while he's crying that he wrote
specifically for her
uh reached the star i think it was
called wow and not a dry eye in the
house oh my gosh
and that was really a highlight and
while the couple hasn't shared that song
publicly yet
the two have shared their love with e.t
over the years
and it'll give you all the feels i think
i'm as big as fans gwen i learned a lot
from
from gwen it's incredible to have a best
friend like that guy